c'est après
[Applaudissements]
oh
après que j'étais pas très concentré
20h40 on est en direct sur ces 8 et
après il y aura à prendre
julia combes et qui sera là c'est génial
bonsoir bonsoir il fait peur très peur
mais effectivement alors on commence à
rentrer chez moi attachée aux politiques
oui bien évidemment je suis enfin duo
oui allez on forme un duo politique
politiques partis politiques après la
sphère des sextos et des photos un peu
olé olé l'ancien porte-parole d'
emmanuel macron benjamin griveaux à
trouver un nouvel emploi et s'est rendu
à son bureau dès ce matin mais les
images
[Applaudissements]
comment je la commence bien bien bien sa
mallette
[Rires]
c'est bientôt le grand retour de mission
massing heures sur tf1 en exclusivité
mondiale carrément nous avons les
premières images du premier candidat
[Applaudissements]
jerry des mythes je sais pas si ça va et
people eh bien c'est la réconciliation
dans le corps à l'idée l'oreille david
lui ont même offert un masque à laëtitia
cool il est caustique mais nous sommes
un petit peu de sport s'il vous plaît on
va commencer par un fait divers dans les
grand plaisir fait divers
mercredi jour des enfants et pourtant
après avoir disparu des écrans télé les
télétubbies sont au coeur d'une vaste
affaire de grand banditisme en effet
tinky winky l'ipsi gepci inc
emery ont été arrêtés pour trafic
international de des robins des chats
bardage et j'aurais d'abord des chars
des véhicules de prestige
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment des mecs qui ont volé un
truc comme ça c'est bien à quoi bon
aller ou du sport effectivement le sport
reste du football et le football reste
sympa
le fils de michael schumacher lui aussi
passionné de sports mécaniques est bien
parti pour succéder à son père la haute
pression non non et non
alors je porte toujours par toujours
neymar
la star du brésilienne du psg a été
testé positif
aujourd'hui au cours d'un virus pourtant
hier à la sortie de l'entraînement le
joueur paraissait en pleine forme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'était le jt a pas hésité de
patrick s'offrait merci mais très sympa
d'être avec vous merci
[Applaudissements]